where is that
I gave it sighs it looks really good
so let's print lot sprinkles okay square
with bubblegum on it a bit weird and
then I taste go together a case I
prohibit potatoes or I will give it
seven out of 5 stars
I would definitely eat that again the
pearl again element
tiny taste I'd wanna eat this so cute I
like the old style um so it's too much
sweet stuff and I don't really like it
5:05
I'll give it a three y'all that's really
really good I think it down think it's
good to come back hiss mm-hmm I really
like about it is the jellies turn out
good it's really different
and it has like a kick to it won't touch
that bubble cup he's good I bet scale
one to five I would definitely end up
again hi
typical old mill cookie I like this one
tasted worse
five outside probably a five and I give
it a four I think Australian biscuits
are like an American food so little but
this add different flavors I think
they're very very good the green chili
and biscuits are awesome
um I'll finish it all right or give it
to my mom your mom can have one myself